want to know what's heating up in  theaters this weekend Logan loses you to  draw the world is not the same as watch  Hugh Jackman stars in his last x-men  movie Logan as the metal claws superhero  his task of protecting a young you go  where does he right after his child is  killed a grieving man gets invited to  meet God at a mysterious forest cabin in  the shack maybe for you there's a  tomorrow a girl realizes how much she  has to lose and gain as she relives the  day of her death and before I fall it's  because hold on go 1 million let's check  out this week's the anticipation  [Music]  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time  on weekend ticket  Oh  [Music]